一個月的時間又過去了
敲破碗的AI更新大補帖終於又來啦 這個月的AI的更新真的是非常可以
每一個都可以直接應用在生活上
不管是PDF檢視 報告格式更新 或者是官方提供的提示詞優化器
看完之後絕對會讓你立刻想要上機使用
嗨各位又是我AJ
這集又到了我們大家的最愛 每個月一次的AI更新大補帖時間
跟上一次的主題 好玩 不太一樣
這一次的更新 更多是讓我們覺得說用 實用 來形容更加的適合
趁現在操作之前先幫我 按讚 訂閱 開啟小叮當
讓每一次的AI更新你都能夠牢牢收藏
永遠的比其他人還要走的更前面 那廢話不多說
那我們開始吧
超級好料分享時間 泛科學院終於又受到YouTube的邀請
來制作免費的認證線上課程啦
這次我們製作了一堂專門為國小高年級還有國中生制作的互動式課程
課程名稱叫做「少年們的AI簡報影音大作戰」
我們會通過 5 堂課的過程
陪著各位一起從認識Gemini的基礎應用打造一個精美的自我介紹文章
在透過AI提示語的方式 做出人生中第一份專屬於自己的自我介紹簡報
記得運用跟Gemini互動的技巧製作專屬的講稿
最後在使用Google系統內建的錄製功能
製作出一份獨一無二的AI簡報影音大作
課程完全免費
任何時候都可以在泛科學院頻道的【課程】分頁里面觀看
重點來了
只要跟著這 5 堂課一起學習並且完成屬於自己的AI影音大作
就可以通過課程下方的連結 前往台灣數位文化協會的網站進行投稿
只要你投稿成功
我們就會頒發給你一張絕無僅有的YouTube Learning證書
讓你的自主學習再添一個有力的證明
所以看到這邊的師長 爸媽 同學們
行動不如馬上行動
趕緊帶著孩子們一起來加入「少年們的AI影音簡報大作戰」吧
首先第一個 Nano Banana 他正式的進入到Google 的這個 Gemini 網頁版
那這東西最近大家根本就是玩爛的
但是呢 最近有網友找到一個非常有趣的功能
就是要用以下的提示語 請將這個Google地圖上的地標制作成等距圖像
僅限於建築物跟相關元素
以玩具模型的風格創建它
同時要保有這張圖原本Google map輪廓不變
圖像跟地圖兩者很好的銜接在一起
你要給他什麽圖呢
很簡單你就去Google Map上 找個你喜歡的地方啊
比如說 這個艋舺龍山寺好了
這個地標一定要顯示艋舺龍山寺 這個有地標的這個圖像
這是我們測試的心得
然後我們就很簡單的把它截個螢幕的圖
好然後接下來就把它丟回去我們剛剛的這個
指令裡面
那記得這個Banana的這個圖像要打開 好然後呢我們就可以按送出
出現了一個非常可愛的艋舺龍山寺圍繞的這個照片
我們之前設計的時候測試的時候 我們還要看另外一張圖大概是長得像
這樣子
所以 你可以在全世界各地的Google Map上找到一個你喜歡的地標
然後把它截圖下來之後呢
丟進去給 nano banana 他就會呈現出許許多多有創意的呈現的方式
好下一個 Grok 有提供了一個PDF的檢視功能
所以你找很簡單的去上傳一份文件
上課有用到的一份這個Google cloud推出了一個cloud threat horizon report
好里面有很多東西 不重要我們就把它上傳直接送出
那送出之後 他就會把這個報告開始去整理一些摘要跟重點
但這不是我們想要的東西我們就把它停下來
當你有了一份PDF把它傳到Grok上面去之後 點開這份PDF
現在會有一個這個預覽的這個視窗
那當你想要去請AI幫你特別去分析什麽的時候呢
其實這個就跟當初的這個ChatPDF提供的功能非常非常像
你就把它選起來
那這時候你就可以把它當成引用然後來去問AI問題
或者是你可以要求他幫你解釋
所以Grok可是一個非常非常 我覺得非常非常新的功能
然後他目前也不太會需要跟你收什麽錢
所以免費的額度之下
他給你的東西其實還蠻多的 所以如果你那個ChatPDF額度用完了
或者是你的ChatGPT額度用光光啦
那還記得Grok 現在有一個AI檢視PDF的功能 輕松的去閱讀一些
英文的這些PDF的文件
所以你看他就幫你解釋說這段文字出自這篇文章下半年的報告
然後核心的意義拆解 研究顯示主要入口點是憑證洩漏
配置錯誤 次要的這些東西
所以你看我只是幫你選了這樣一段的內容
然後他會用給你非常非常詳盡的一個解釋
甚至給你一些這個基於這個報告的一些行動的這些建議
所以他會把這份報告里面的其他資料也都讀進去
然後給你一個比較完整的一個說明的文件
這是一個還蠻好用的功能
好 下一個 NotebookLM 最近做了我覺得蠻有趣的一個更新
好那你現在可以進到NotebookLM里面去
之後一樣這個開一個筆記本什麽的
進入這個好一個AI筆記本之後
現在工作室這個地方 出現了一點點小變化
看看你的賬號現在是什麽樣的一個狀態
那我們自己 有遇到兩種形式
一種就是4格的形式
然後報告這邊會出現一個New
點一下這個報告
他會出現這個格式
不管你要去自訂報告 簡介文件 研讀指南 網誌文章
然後下面這個建議格式
他會根據你給他的這些來源里面的文件提供你4個
用AI建議你可以怎麽樣去建立報告的格式
當然每一個格式你都可以點下去
然後根據這個 你的需求來去調整你的這些指令
那但是這個指令他會預先幫你生成出來 給你做參考
你就不用自己想
所以如果這樣沒問題你就可以按產生
這樣會生成一份報告
那這報告大概做的大概兩三分鐘而已後其實還蠻快的
但是我們最近又發現有一些人的這個Gmail的賬號他會變成6個框框
那6個框框會長什麽樣子
他的報告里面就只會有這4種文件 指南 問題跟時間軸
你就沒有辦法用AI去自訂
那他反而又提供了兩個功能
第一個叫學習卡 你可以去設定一個標準的片數量
然後難易度去控制
那你也可以要求他去生成一些提示詞 去限制說我想要學習什麽樣的內容
比如說新手資安入門須知之類的
然後我們就按生成
他就會根據你給他這份PDF文件
去幫你生成一個對新手的這樣的一個學習卡的
這個功能
我覺得NotebookLM最近應該也是在做一些功能的AB測試
所以有些人會看到這個
有些人會看到那個
那最終他應該會去用大數據去分析說
大家在使用上面到底哪一個功能是大家比較喜歡的
然後用的比較好的 那最終可能會有些功能會被留下來
但有的功能可能會被捨棄
所以現在各位我不知道你的賬號現在打開是4格還是6格
反正總之如果你看到的話你就可以去試著去試試看
所以你現在看到閃卡已經好了
他就會直接 變成一個這個flash card的形式
那你可以點開看答案好翻過來翻過去
一次53張卡太多了吧
看來重點真的是很多
那這個是閃卡的功能
另外一個測驗建立的功能 一樣你可以去選擇較少的問題
標準的問題較多的問題
控制他的難易度然後你可以去設定說我的主題是一樣
新手資安入門教學 簡單 然後就然後去生成
我們的這個資安測驗好了
好那一樣他就幫你做成了這個測驗 答對答錯你可以幫你去自己去點選
下一個大家熟悉的 ChatGPT 最近更新了一個小小的功能叫做分支
什麽是分支 比如說我就可以跟他講說幫我說明Nano banana
你在跟這些ChatGPT對話的時候
常常你可能會遇到一個很尷尬的狀況就是
我在跟他對話對話 然後對話到了一半我可能就岔題了
岔題了之後 我可能一邊我想要去說 針對AI專家
撰寫 nano banana的說明文字
好 可是呢
有時候我又想要說 我要針對一般的社會大眾來去說明什麽是Nano banana
那你在跟AI互動的時候
是不是常常會
前面討論的事情跟我後面討論的事情是兩個不同的事情
所以ChatGPT也想到了這個問題
最近他們提供一個功能叫做分支
比如說我現在這個可以針對專家撰寫AI的這個文字
然後拿去做這樣那個生成那這個分支應該就要往專家討論去了
那我沒有想要
在這個里面去討論跟一般人的這個對話的形式
所以我就可以在原始的這個地方我想要來分支他一下
所以你就可以在新聊天中分支
他就會把那個對話串之前的內容 你看從Nano banana說明分支出來
那這個分支我就可以跟他說
請針對完全沒有AI圖像生成概念的民眾撰寫一份說明文件
所以你看我就是從剛剛的這個上下文
然後直接單獨的在這個分支里面我就是只處理
比如說這個是對新手淺顯易懂的方式
可是我在另外一個對話串里面
那我就是會去處理對專家來說
我們要去講一些就是專家能夠討論的這些語彙這個分支的功能
如果你今天在使用這個ChatGPT的時候
管是對話也好啦
程式碼生成也好啦
你自己會弄的有點灰格格姆薩薩找不到
有時候很多的這個需求都要混在一起的時候
這時候你就要記得GPT現在多了一個新功能叫做分支
下一個ChatGPT 最近更新了一個我覺得蠻重要的小功能
你可以在這個GPT5的這個模型選單里面選擇這個thinking模式
然後現在你可以有兩種模型可以選擇
一種叫做標準的thinking
一種叫做進階的thinking
在標準的這種thinking模式 他會說兼顧思考跟速度
簡單來說就是跑比較快 那如果遇到一個難題 你希望他延長思考的時間
那你就可以開啟這個進階的模式
要求他想久一點 再來給你一個答案
那這邊我們可以問他
一個非常困難的問題就是請問麥當勞的薯條跟肯德基的薯條哪個比較好吃
好 正在思考啦
這是一個主觀的問題
不需要查詢網頁
麥當勞薯條在美國有牛肉味
台灣使用植物油比較脆 肯德基薯條較厚
有時候是脆薯有時候加辣椒粉
哇進行的非常深刻的思考啊
喜歡脆感選麥當勞
重口味選肯德基
喜歡搭醬依照個人口味選擇建議 想要熱的薯條可以要求不加鹽
想要吃剛起鍋的爽脆
想要吃馬鈴薯
那能開肯德基聖
懶人結論快速比較小技巧如果你要二選一拿就
吃麥當勞
想吃飽吃肯德基 這麽無聊的問題都可以想這麽久 GPT 蠻好的
好那這時候你問我說那到底該怎麽選呢
經過我們自己的測試
製作人花了蠻多時間跟我做一些測試跟討論
給各位個結論如果你要快當然就是選這個mini
thinking mini這個模型那如果你今天要處理的事情比較覆雜
那當然你還是要選thinking模型
那當然說實話如果你是免費仔那那就沒什麽好選的
就是都是預設讓他該跑是幹嘛跑幹嘛 你可以用一些COT的技巧
請AI先思考之後再回答 這是一個很簡單的提示工程
在GPT5的時代可以去使用
在我們自己測試的時候
我們發掘到說其實在標準的那個thinking mini的這個狀態之下
其實GPT還是有可能會產生一些幻覺的現象
所以請AI多多思考
之後去做一些內部的叠代是有機會會降低和幻覺產生的可能性
我們自己體感的這個經驗是這樣子
那如果你自己有一些使用的經驗
也歡迎你在影片下面留言跟我們做一個分享
最後跟各位分享我們自己的一些 小小的工作流的技巧
如果你只知道快速拿到草稿
我們自己會用mini的這個模式先出2到3種不同的方向
然後從這里面選一個我們喜歡的
然後我們將會用標準的模式來去擴寫成可對外制作的這些版本啊
像我們這些影片的腳本的出稿其實都用這種方式去生成的
好那最後一個我們再額外加碼一個小小的工具GPT官方的prompt生成器
首先 你可以來到這個地方
然後你進來之後呢 你需要先登錄一下
完成登錄之後呢 你會看到這個叫做optimize for GPT5
這個是open AI官方所推出的一個GPT5提示詞的優化器
所以你就可以很簡單的去把你的提示詞寫在這個地方
好比如說請作為一個資深的求職教練幫助我挖掘我自己的優點
並且最終制作一個我的履歷表
那就很簡單直接按一下這個optimize
好那你會看到他正在optimizing prompt
他會有一些幾個這個不同的階段 調整格式
然後確認
這個助理生成這些內容
那這個是一個免費的功能
所以你只要找得到這個網址 我覺得這網址躲的還蠻里面的
找到這個網址之後 你只要簡單登錄你的Open AI的賬號
基本上你都可以免費做這樣的使用
不用費用
所以 你看從原本的這個一句提示詞
他就把我變成角色目標操作指引
輸出格式
其他提示 結束條件
那這個東西是遵循著他們官方提出來的這個best practice啊
這個是GPT5的prompting guide的這個best practice 是這個文章 制作出來的這個工具
我覺得這個東西還蠻好用的 生成完畢之後
就直接按copy就把它覆制出來
就可以回到ChatGPT開一個新聊天
把提示貼上
那這樣子你就獲得了一個非常完整結構了在GPT5時代一個標準的提示詞
以上就是我們這一期的5個每個月我覺得很重要的AI工具的更新
覺得哪一個比較實用呢
如果你喜歡我們的影片的話麻煩幫我們訂閱留言加分享
那我們下期再見嘍拜拜